career conference for females in Tech
was taken over by male attendees they
were there just purely for the career
fair social media Clips filmed at the
Grace Hopper the world's largest
gathering of women technologists show
men standing in line to meet with
recruiters this is a space for women in
Tech this is one of those few limited
resources that isn't for you it's for us
some of the male attendees reportedly
lied about being non-binary just to get
in but it's interesting that
[Music]
thear
shut
[__] oh
[__] no shut
up
why I got
me that was
awesome let's keep washing shall we I
think I wased it up that's F let's wash
let's keep washing here we go that's
awesome but it's interesting that the
large majority of the people that
actually ended up in the event had name
tags with he him and have no searchable
history of identifying as
non-binary um you can be non-binary and
have pronouns he
him that's absolutely thing what is
non-binary mean it's one of the most
useless dumbest categorizations of
gender expression I've ever seen and I
don't believe it's real but some people
identify it and it's open enough that
you can have he him as your pro as
your as your pronouns and be
non-binary you guys made this clown
world now you just mad that people are
rocking the makeup
boo Bo listen you can't make the circus
come to town and be mad when clowns show
up listen that's you listen you a whole
state fair there are these rules that
was put in
place by not
me and not these dudes either okay and
and and
you're going to navigate through life
with those rules and do those those are
new rules and there's a bunch of
loopholes and people are going to use
the loopholes oh they're going to find
them they're going to find them to get
ahead no matter what
and according to the rules thou was set
by not me they're right I don't know
what the problem is with him being a
powerful
woman why can't he be a woman in Tech
huh why can't he be a female
technologist let him do her thing listen
my
guy you're
laughing but the sad part is that's what
it is I'm laughing but they
winning that's exactly what it is right
now that's what that's where we at so
it's like and the thing the thing that
happen is that we we've been saying that
it is going to be to the detriment of
women and we see it happen so
that's like a case of I hate to say it
but I Told You So several Tech workers
defended the men for trying to
capitalize on job opportunities not
meant for them seeing that the entire
concept was wrong let's be honest there
is no need for a conference just for
women because if it was the opposite of
for men then it would be sexist just
because you are a woman doesn't give you
the right to talk to a big yeah but I'm
probably sure they're probably going to
say they created that kind of
opportunity to give an opportunity to
women who don't normally have a chance
but is there an opportunity for people
that are more ostracized that's what
they're going to say okay so there's an
opportunity for people that are more
ostracized yeah and who's more
ostracized than non-binary
people so what are we talking about all
right hold up there's a there's a
serious you yesterday it became clear
that there a far greater number of
cisgender mening
anticipate
simp we
[Applause]
register St res you're passing out we
did so because we thought that we could
come here and take space to try a
job we need male
allies we need men who want to celebrate
women who want to work with and
for I'm going to get so much [__]
tonight yeah every time I see these
types I'm just like I'm like I'm going
to get so much [__] tonight we need oh
yes you could woo my dick yeah that's
what I that's when I see that that's
what I see who are you to decide whether
they relying or not who are
you and it's you're very off to to to
ask someone whether there are would you
ask a trans woman if she really is or
not to prove herself no you don't do
that that's not the rules made by me
yeah so
you thought it would be
easy easy peasy lemon squeezy but it
looks like it's difficult difficult
lemon difficult a
it so let them be cuz there nobody to
say like they
lied you're nobody to say that oh what
whenever we told you that some people
are going to take advantage yeah it's
only going to be a small percentage well
okay I mean listen we can all talk about
this you know what I just think I think
what it really comes down to is like
think what you want about the train
stuff this stuff I think we can all
agree or most of us can agree the
non-binary stuff is just [__] it's
is made up
nonsense hey let's be honest this is
nonsense that's what I think about this
whole thing uh do I think it's great
that uh males were out here taking up
space for females obviously not I don't
think non-binary people who are
authentically non-binary should be in
those spaces either if it's a woman's
conference for females the non-binary
people should not be there neither
should train trans people be there but
me since you wanted to open the door of
this nonsense you should take it all you
should take the non-binary people the
other non-binary people who are not
actually non-binary because like how are
you going to verify are you going to
look through their social media posts to
make sure that they've been identifying
as nonbinary for a long time are you
going to demand that they have a certain
type of pronouns cuz if you are then we
can extend that to transness how much
does someone need to transition before
they're actually trans can I show up in
a wig and say that I'm trans do I have
to actually go through any surgery do I
have to make any kind of effort what's
the degree of trans I need to exhibit
for how long do I need to exhibit it
before it's acceptable at the end of the
day like I said you brought the circus
to town now let the clowns play that's
my
thoughts it is what it is you're going
to have to apply those rules that are
see discriminatory it's for you
basically I can't do that for me I can't
be like no no those rules are
discriminatory if you go against a non-b
person and you're oh you go yeah no I'm
not going to accept in you because
you're not really the
binary that's just discriminatory you're
opening yourself for lawsuits and
lawsuits my guy it's going to be
impossible for you to operate I don't
even think they could do any lwuit I
don't think non-binary people could suit
cuz the law doesn't recognize non-binary
[__] wow so I don't think it's that deep
I don't because you're not a protected
class because you're
non-binary it's not like being gay or
something from a legal standpoint so
there is no lawsuit to be I don't know
but anyway I'm not a lawyer I let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below no it's like you have to be a
protected class protected class is gay
folks uh minorities I don't think it's
religious I think it's gender based so
binary is is gender no no on the basis
of
ethnicity or race man I'm not a lawyer
and you're talking jeers to me right now
you don't know what protected classes
are no
okay I'm I'm not going to go in line
until like yeah of course I do I don't